I found it kind of interesting or nice
to be the guy who's done sing a bit
dastardly on a show yeah I mean I always
say that it's better to play the baddies
and the goodies I mean I I couldn't have
done what Bradley did which is being
basically the out-and-out hero for the
whole five years you know he had floors
yes but I mean like to be the hero of
the show because I guess a bit a bit
boring you know the guy that always
saves a day it's nice but after like the
fourth Eroica momiji do you like okay it
was nice to play ambiguous and he's nice
play complicated and then I mean not out
and right dastardly evil but like he had
like floors major floors so that's
always good to play joining when you did
because obviously the cast had
established in a way it wasn't it yeah
no it's alright I mean it was more my
trepidation than that what they were
giving me was more my worry I mean the
first a read-through they're all giving
each other hugs like they haven't seen
each other for a like a holiday you know
and they were just like that was in the
new kid in the middle but they're lovely
I mean they all welcomed me with open
arms to the show
I did my first couple of weeks on
filming with just Colleen and Bradley so
it was really nice to have the sort of
the two spearheads of the show to sort
of take me under their wing and sort of
explain lots of stuff to me about how
the show would affect me he afterwards
which is good and then and then
throughout different blocks outside from
within the night and then managed to
finally do a scene with angel which took
people like four five months to do and
finally do a scene with Richard Wilson
so yeah I was ticking them off as I was
going along but the memories that you
have from the show which there wasn't
really thick in your mind the memories
my first day ivo said this my first day
was a bit of a shock to the system it
was like we was filming the first two
episodes of merlin there was the snow
stuff so it was my first day was in the
Brecon Beacons is beautiful they covered
this whole quarry in fake snow it was
green-screen
they literally dumped me in the deep end
I'm I just came out of my trailer and I
sort of looked at the set I was like and
that was my fear so I just come from
doing a small army drama was like period
rum for the BBC like the weekend before
so that the differences in tone was
drastic and I sort of didn't prepare
myself for it
I guess the stuff that I was doing with
Katie's always sticks out as well I was
I love the first time I got to use magic
such that everyone was reading the
script through I was like yeah
I took it took me to like episode 9 to
solve out the little flare thing but
yeah I mean the old show is good you
know you I watch your back now sometimes
I think well that's lonely lovely on
memories I've got talking about Merlin
memories do you think it might come back
in any form I mean it's always like talk
about Merlin the movie will there be one
I mean if there were would you want to
be possible yeah one of them questions
that can't really come from me or caught
I can't answer because it's um it's
Colin show really and Johnny and
Julian's you know he would have to say
you couldn't have a show without him you
couldn't so if he didn't if he said no
then I then it's always gonna be a no I
think and I think he's done brilliantly
by moving away from me and going into
theater and concentrating on his work in
his craft which is what he's always
wanted to do really so no I don't think
so I mean I would like it to come back
only because I want to because I had a
very short time on the show more of a
like an indulgence thing for me but
honestly I don't make it work was it
like filming that death scene haha death
things are funny I die in like maybe
everything I do everything I've done
again either get shot or I get like yeah
I die and everything so death seems a
funny I really thought that Justin the
director dealt with it brilliantly and
we talked in length about months before
we filmed that scene between me and
Bradley how the fight scene was going to
work how quick it needed to be or not
and the moments and so we talked in
length oh so when the day finally came
it wasn't really that sad you know you
sort of get on with it
and the fact that we film everything out
of order I filmed the death scene and
then two scenes afterwards as back on my
feet fighting him or doing something or
talking - magana so it's there's
nothing's in order so you don't can't
like die and that be your last day on
the job you know it's it's weird yeah
eventually the cast members moving on to
theatre I know you've been doing theater
as well and they took you with Kenneth
Branagh the Manchester International
Festival doing Macbeth no less how was
that that was great that was amazing
that was it was weird when I got that
job I thought that's the bit this of one
of the biggest steps I can do away from
Mordred and then the first day they gave
me a broadswords now it's just like
cartoon earth I thought I was making a
big jump and then suddenly we're doing
fighting scenes and I just I have just
done this for eight months now I loved
it I mean I love Shakespeare and I'll
and
and you know these are he's the god of
Shakespeare and he's and he's fantastic
and he taught me so much and I think
it's always good to sort of veer away
from stuff like that and know I mean my
Beth was brilliant and in the fact that
it showcased all of us off to our talent
and we're going to Broadway next year as
well so that's exciting
so what are you looking forward to about
that and how do you think it will differ
the experience I was gonna do a crazy I
think because it's going to be we're
gonna be six months away from the whole
thing so to come back and we've only got
two weeks three rehearsals so it's gonna
be like learning lines getting very
quickly and then sort of starting again
and I don't know how many of the
original casts are gonna be back as well
so that's gonna be weird I just want to
go to New York I'm just looking forward
to being this is that the weird thing of
like when you're a young actor you have
oh I do anywhere have like a tick list
of things that you want to do you know
like things you want to do and
especially the more contains within
theatre and you go I want to do
something with I want to work at the RSC
I want to work at the National I want to
go to the West End I wanna go to
Broadway before I'm 30 so I haven't went
to the RSC I've worked at the National I
haven't got to the West End yet but I'm
gonna go to Broadway some chicken wings
off very slowly yeah I like the idea you
want to take this and you're working
through it slowly and steadily yeah I
mean obviously you can't force these
things things just happened naturally
but you know I mean yeah the Broadway
thing is like I know I know actors are
like 6065 you know who've never gone to
Broadway so the fact that you can do
when you're 25 I went in to meet with
the show that's already successful so
but the show that's already successful
because that's the weird thing some
people go to Broadway with the show that
maybe he's on right over here so it's
good to go with a massive critical
backing and know that they're gonna lap
it up you know over there was it like
acting and being directed by Kenneth
Branagh weird you know I'll be honest it
was weird because he'd be doing a scene
with him and then he'd sort of just come
out of the scene and then give you a No
you go yeah your Macbeth then you all
said the director that's very strange
but no it was good I mean like I said
everything that he said was just like
pearls of wisdom I guess so so I have to
soak everything up like a sponge and
something that might not immediately
show itself in your acting but it might
you know something that he might say in
that rehearsal room might affect me in
another theatre job maybe 20 years from
now do you know what I mean so he's one
of them ones where you have to sort of
let it fester on that tick list what
else is there are those specific
directors or actors or kind of genres or
anything like that that you would say oh
yeah I wanna do that I really want to be
in Dr Hill I know I heard you like to be
adopted yeah miss kid I mean like it's
come from it's weird because I love
Doctor Who before I was an actor so I've
sort of come out here from the side
where I'm like at that point now where I
could actually potentially be in it some
like so I'm trying my utmost to keep
dropping in and every interview I can do
no it's good I mean like I'd love to be
in doctor Tony because I'm a massive fan
of it you know that would be the one
thing that I'd be like as far as TV goes
would be a massive tick list I did
jokingly say to my agent get the day I
said if you get me on Doctor Who
I'm gonna quit acting because I said
there's nothing more to be done I said
even if I'm inside a tin Dalek shell you
can't actually see my face but I know
I'm there then I'm then I'll be happy
yeah no see what do you think about
after all the speculation we had who's
gonna be the next doctor piece of
Holliday is step forward yeah I mean I
was twelve to one on that day didn't I
was like every was going is he you and
I'm like I was in my house you know
having a full English going it's not me
because otherwise I could be at the
studio you should like yes it's totally
me yeah no I know I'm having P is a
great choice when David left I thought
they were gonna go older I always think
they should go older because that's how
we in my eyes as how he's been Hartnell
and Troutman is that so
so yeah I mean that day that when they
and Nancy it was like a big circus I've
never seen anything so hyped up in my
entire life so I thought if big putting
a young actor to walk out in front of a
whole audience of who fans said god help
them you know so when it was Peter it
sort of made sense because he's the sort
of guy that could handle that he can
handle a live Q&A in a circus frenzy
like that he was you know he's
experienced enough to do it and the fact
that Moffat said that they had him in
four years ago and they were considering
him sort of sort of shows you that
he's the right man for the job really
the fantastic actress why just you know
so many different roles he's good at
comedy drama yeah and I think he's gonna
bring that dark mysterious the proper
dark mysterious I mean everyone has
elements of it you know but I mean the
more of the granddad type role the sort
of early stuff I think more of a nun
less of the Companions falling in love
with him which is all right for a while
but when it's everyone that walked into
the TARDIS goes oh I love you it's a bit
like okay you know but I think it's
better that it's gonna have that I just
grabbed its ass you know he doesn't have
to force and he doesn't have to force
her status you mediate think like that
guy you can control the TARDIS and be a
unit be the doctor
you